>> Tucker: LOOKS LIKE SAM
BANKMAN-FRIED COMMITTED THE
LARGEST FINANCIAL FRAUD IN
MODERN HISTORY BUT HE'S NOT IN
PRISON.
HE DIDN'T TRESPASS IN THE
CAPITOL.
WHAT'S INTERESTING SUR NOT
ALLOWED TO KNOW -- IS YOU'RE NOT
ALLOWED TO KNOW THE IDENTIFY OF
THE TWO PEOPLE THAT HELPED TO
PUT UP SAM BANKMAN-FRIED'S BOND.
HIS LAWYERS EVEN ARGUED IN COURT
TO KEEP THE NAMES MASKED TO
SHIELD THEM FROM PUBLIC
CRITICISM.
NOW, THE MEDIA OUTLETS TOOK A
TON OF MONEY FROM SAM
BANKMAN-FRIED LIKE.
[INDISCERNIBLE]
HAVEN'T RETURNED THE MONEY --
THAT'S STOLEN MONEY, AND THEY
DON'T SEEM VERY INTERESTED IN
HOW THIS HAPPENED.
WE ARE INTERESTED.
WE JUST FINISHED A DOCUMENTARY,
IN FACT, CALLED "SAM
BANKMAN-FRIED, THE STORY OF FTX"
OUT THURSDAY ON FOXNATION.
HERE'S A PREVIEW.
>> ONE OF HIS STRATEGIES WAS TO
CLUTTER HIS SENTENCES WITH TECH
JARGON SO NO ONE UNDERSTOOD WHAT
HE WAS SAYING.
>> THAT POSITION WAS OVER
KLATTRALIZED A YEAR --
COLLATERALIZED A YEAR AGO.
THERE'S A CORRELATED COLLAPSE IN
ITS ASSETS OVER THE LAST MONTH.
>> I'M NO CRYPT TOLL CURRENCY
EXPERT OR FINANCE EXPERT BUT I
DON'T THINK THAT YOU ANSWERED MY
QUESTION.
>> I HAVE A GENERAL RULE OF
THUMB, IF YOU CANNOT EXPLAIN IT
TO A 14-YEAR-OLD, THAT MEANS
EITHER YOU DON'T UNDERSTAND IT
YOURSELF OR YOU DON'T UNDERSTAND
AND YOU'RE TRYING TO CONFUSE THE
AUDIENCE FOR A REASON THAT HAS
TO DO WITH YOUR OWN
SELF-INTERESTED GAIN.
>> MR. BANKMAN-FRIED HAS BEEN
ABLE TO CONFUSE INTERVIEWERS BY
TALKING IN CIRCLES.
>> NOTHING THAT SBF SAID SINCE
THE FRAUD WAS EXPOSED HAS BEEN
COHERENT EVEN INTO THIS
SOPHISTICATED OBSERVER OF
FINANCIAL MARKETS.
I THINK THAT'S NOT JUST AN
ACCIDENT.
IT IS BY DESIGN.
IT'S ANOTHER DEFLECTION TACTIC.
>> Tucker: SO THE MAN YOU JUST
SAW IN THAT CLIP IS ONE OF THE
PEOPLE WHO ACT AS A SHERPA FORCE
AS WE TRIED TO UNDERSTAND WHAT
WAS HAPPENING WITH SAM
BANKMAN-FRIED.
HE'S A FREQUENT GUEST OF OUR
SHOW, EXECUTIVE CHAIRMAN OF
STRIVE ASSET MANAGEMENT.
HE JOINS US IN STUDIO TONIGHT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR COMING
ON.
I LOVED YOUR POINT.
I THINK IT'S ONE OF THE -- IT'S
ONE OF THE TRUEST GUIDES TO
OTHER PEOPLE'S TALKING BUT TELL
ME WHY SAM BANKMAN-FRIED SEEMED
TO BE TREATED SO MUCH MORE
GENTLY THAN YOUR AVERAGE
CRIMINAL DEFENDANT?
>> IT'S BECAUSE WE HAD THE
ENTIRE DEFLECTION TACTIC SET UP.
IT WASN'T JUST THE JARGON.
IT WAS THE ESG SMOKE SCREEN.
IT WAS THE GOOD GUY WHO WAS
ENGAGED IN EFFECTIVE ALTRUISM,
FUNDING DEMOCRATIC CANDIDATES.
HE KNEW HOW TO PLAY THE GAME TO
BE ABLE TO CREATE THE APPEARANCE
HE CARED ABOUT SOMETHING OTHER
THAN PROFIT AND POWER WHEN IN
FACT HE CARED ONLY ABOUT MORE
PROFIT AND POWER FOR HIMSELF.
BUT THE THING THAT WAS MOST
STRIKING TO ME ABOUT THIS STORY,
TUCKER, IS THIS IS NOT A DEVIANT
THAT IS DIFFERENT FROM THE REST
OF WALL STREET OPERATES BUT HOW
FAMILIAR HIS STORY IS IT'S THE
SAME STORY WE SAW BACK IN 2008.
I THINK THERE ARE A LOT OF
SIMILARITIES.
IT'LL MAKE A LOT OF PEOPLE MAD
TO HEAR THIS.
THERE ARE A LOT OF SIMILARITIES
TO WHAT THE ESG PROMOTING
FINANCIAL INSTITUTIONS DO TODAY.
WHAT DID HE DO?
HE TOOK CLIENT FUNDS WITHOUT
THEIR PERMISSION AND DID IT.
THE LARGEST INSTITUTIONS ARE
USING SOMEONE ELSE'S MONEY
WITHOUT THEIR PERMISSION TO
ADVANCE THEIR OWN AGENDAS.
WHAT I FIND MOST FASCINATING OF
THIS STORY IS NOT THIS GUY THAT
IS 30 YEARS OLD THAT MADE A LOT
OF MONEY.
THAT'S AN INTERESTING DETAIL.
IT'S INTERESTING FOR EVERYONE TO
LOOK IN THE MIRROR WHO?
WALL STREET AND EVERYONE ELSE TO
ASK THEMSELVES HOW DISSIMILAR
HIS STORY IS TO MAINSTREAM
MARKETS.
>> Tucker: THESE ARE PEOPLE
MOTIVATED BY A LOT OF THINGS BUT
WE HAVE REGULATORS THAT ARE
SUPPOSED TO KEEP THAT WITHIN THE
BOUNDS LIKE GARY GENTZLER.
WHERE ARE THEY?
>> THEY'RE BUSY FOCUSED ON
ADVANCING THOSE SAME AGENDAS.
RIGHT?
WHY ARE THEY PROPAGATING ESG
DISCLOSURE RULES WHEN IN FACT
THEY SHOULD BE FOCUSED ON
PREVENTING PEOPLE FROM LOSING
MONEY.
>> Tucker:
[LAUGHTER]
>> YOU WOULD THINK THIS IS AN
OBJECTIVE.
THE IRONY IS THEY'LL USE THIS AS
A CATALYST SO SAY WE NEED TO
HAVE GREATER PURVIEW OF
REGULATING CRYPTOCURRENCIES WHEN
THIS IS A MANAGERIAL CLASS
THAT'S ADVANCING POLITICAL
AGENDA.
THE MORE YOU'RE DOING THAT THE
LESS YOU'RE DOING THE JOB YOU'RE
ACTUALLY SUPPOSED TO DO.
THAT'S THE STORY OF THE
ADMINISTRATIVE STATE, THE SCC
INCLUDED AS WE KNOW IT.
>> Tucker: IF IT'S TRUE WHAT
SAM BANKMAN-FRIED DID IS NOT SO
DIFFERENT FROM WHAT A LOT OF
PEOPLE ARE DOING NOW, ARE YOU
CONCERNED ABOUT THE STABILITY OF
OUR FINANCIAL SYSTEM?
>> SO, LOOK, I'VE HAD CONCERNS
DATING BACK TO 2008.
THE THING WE DIDN'T LET HAPPEN
IN THIS COUNTRY, TUCKER S WHEN
THOSE BANKS ACTUALLY ERRED BACK
THEN, WE SHOULD HAVE LET THEM
FALL AND ACTUALLY TEACH THE
SYSTEM ITS LESSON.
INSTEAD, THE LESSON WE TAUGHT IS
THE WORSE YOU ACT, THE MORE
LIKELY YOU ARE TO GET BAILED OUT
BY THE SYSTEM.
SBF WAS A YOUNG GUY.
THAT'S THE SYSTEM HE GREW UP.
WHAT ELSE DO YOU EXPECT BUT A
NEXT GENERATION OF FRAUDSTERS TO
DO THE SAME THING A DECADE AND A
HALF LATER?
>> Tucker: CLEARLY HIS PARENTS
ENCOURAGED THIS YOU CAN IMAGINE
THIS KID PULLING THE SAME SCAM
AT 13.
OH, ISN'T HE CUTE?
HE'S SO SMART!
OK.
GREAT TO SEE YOU.